what we're learning about the genome is
going to give us a whole new set of
therapeutic interventions that are going
to be much more targeted to the problem
at the molecular level it'll give us a
chance to practice medicine in a
preventive mode instead of focusing our
efforts on people who have already
gotten sick and it won't just be in this
area of predicting future illness if you
do fall ill you're likely to have your
DNA checked in some instances before you
get the medicine that's going to help
you so that it's the right drug for you
at the right dose because sequencing
technology is improving all the time
where potentially reaching a point where
genetic testing can move out of a
traditional laboratory and into new
areas say for example of pharmacy when
people nowadays are talking about
developing gene tests that will predict
all sorts of other things which are not
in general thought of Israeli inherited
diseases although they've got a genetic
background it's going to be very hard
indeed to explain to the average person
who isn't deeply immersed in the
statistics of this stuff exactly how
meaningful and useful those bits of
information are in terms of planning
their lives the government got rather
excited about the idea with the Human
Genome Project we could sequence
everybody and the question is whether it
was a good idea and what the social
consequences would be there is something
important that we need to do in society
which is to make sure that I'm
increasing knowledge about people's
individual personal genetic information
is not used
to unfairly discriminate against them I
think people are right to be concerned
about genetic discrimination in either
insurance employment or education at the
moment in the United Kingdom we have a
voluntary moratorium for insurance where
insurance companies have actually agreed
with the government not to discriminate
against people who have had predictive
genetic tests you can develop a DNA
profile which is very substantially
individual specific and this is now the
standard technology both in individual
identification in forensic
investigations and also in establishing
family relationships for example in
paternity disputes and immigration
disputes weathers doubts about whether
the family is genuine or not every
single DNA test has behind a human drama
your profile goes on the database
because you've committed an offence but
can now be used not only to catch you
again if you rear fender incorporate any
relative of the may offend in the future
and I think there's a host of ethical
and moral issues surrounding that and
simply have not been debated this is
going to be the century of biological
research we are going to learn how life
works at a level of detail that people
could not have imagined so if you ask me
what I'm most excited about and I'm not
sure it's five years away it might be
more like 10 or 15 it's a new class of
treatments a new class of behavioral
interventions that no one will even call
genetic it'll just be based on we know
that's how diabetes works and so we
learned how to fix it will the seed of
that knowledge have come from genetics I
believe it will but will it actually
look genetic when it comes to the clinic
I'm not sure it will it'll just be
someone who lives longer a healthier
life because it's something they did
that they don't know trace to genetics
to me that would be the biggest success
you